you see this in a situation where you
may have a 4000 pixel by 4000 pixel
texture that may be fetched from a
server this single fetch can take about
241 milliseconds to download which is
actually pretty fast if you were
actually to chop up that image into
smaller little pixels so for example we
would create 4,000 separate images the
total load time to request all of those
images to occupy the same amount of
space would change drastically in fact
it would actually increase from 241
milliseconds to 4.3 seconds that's an
increase of 17 times with this in mind
it makes sense then that in order to
reduce load times for high-performance
web applications we should group as many
of the small elements together into one
large image to reduce the number of HTTP
requests this process of packing smaller
images into larvae Chur images is known
as texture Atlas indigenous is a single
large image that contains many smaller
sub images each of which can be
referenced independently